armed officers who had the attacker
under surveillance at the time responded
immediately and gave chase
as they confronted the attacker he
turned on them armed with a knife and
the officers fired a number of fatal
shots
the whole incident from start to finish
lasted just over 60 seconds
today the jury in the inquest has
returned a verdict of lawful killing
i want to thank the jury for their
careful examination of the evidence in
this case
but also for the coroner's positive
comments and praise
both towards the investigation team and
the armed officers who responded to the
incident
thankfully armed officers have rarely
discharged their firearms in the course
of their duties
despite being faced with multiple
threats across the country every single
day
i also want to pay tribute to the
courage shown by the officers
in relation to how they pursued the
attacker but also stopped anybody else
coming to harm
it's due credit to armed officers across
this country and again this demonstrates
the true professionalism shown by them
but also their bravery in the face of
danger
police had real concerns about this
attacker both in relation to his
extremist mindset
and also what he may do on his release
from prison
it is for this reason that we
employed and he was monitored
by a very professional and a highly
skilled team
it's for this reason that they were in
the right place at the right time to
intervene and stop this becoming a
murderous attack
lethal force is rare in this country but
as you have heard the evidence in this
case
that once the attack had started lethal
force
was one of the most effective ways of
stopping the attack
managing terrorist offenders in the
community is a really challenging job
and we do that in conjunction with
various other agencies and partners
and and we use a range of tactics and
measures to to monitor people such as
this
i want to reassure everybody though that
we work around the clock tirelessly with
great determinant great determination
and effort to combat any forms of
terrorist acts in this country
incidents such as this
take up a lot of resources and we use
hundreds of officers from across the
country including police staff working
with other agencies and other emergency
services and i want to pay tribute to
their excellent work
i also want to say thank you to the
members of the public that came to the
aid of those that were injured on that
day
staying with them reassuring them until
medical assistants arrive
in relation to the two people that were
injured i'm sure the trauma of that day
will remain with them for some time and
our thoughts go out to them also
lastly a case such as this is a timely
reminder that the terrorist threat is
very real
and the terrorist threat has not gone
away
i therefore encourage everybody to
remain alert and vigilant and report
anything suspicious to the police
thank you very much